Today, I have followed out, we can buy Ivermectin over the color from the drug stores.
I've heard a lot of good information about this drug and cancer can we take it and what
would be the benefit.
So, I have been hesitant to comment about Ivermectin in the past because it's a prescription medication,
most places.
If you just do a Google Scholar search on Ivermectin and cancer, you'll find that there's
a number of studies that are very positive on Ivermectin and cancer.
So, I don't see any problem with taking Ivermectin.
The only thing I would suggest was that it is a medication and we, you know, even though
it's a long-use medication, it was initially in the market years and years ago, very, very,
very few side effects.
I would still think that it would be best to call it a medication that, you know, affect
you in negative ways, but it could have very positive effects.
So, I know there are some people that take Ivermectin every day and it's like, I just want
to go, but why?
I mean, I'm talking people who don't even have cancer, you know, so I don't know that I would
suggest anything like that, but I don't see it, let's say if you're just trying to protect
yourself against COVID or some other weird virus that make a lot to pulse it, might be a good
thing to have it in your arsenal, might be a good thing.
I do think that a lot of medications you can become sensitive to, meaning that if you're
taking it all the time, you're not going to get as much benefit from it.
And saving it, having it in your arsenal to take, let's say if your cancer's doing well
and you're doing really well, then I don't know that I would change that and take that.
Or if, you know, you don't have a virus and you're feeling well, it might be good to have
it in your arsenal if you do need to take it.
But I think it is, obviously it had, when it's phenomenal success with COVID, that's why